if you enjoy random short facts about
entertaining events in history you most
certainly came across this famous
did you know post which says that during
the 1866 austro-prussian war
liechtenstein sided with austria and
went to war with its military which was
80 men strong these 80 soldiers saw no
action during this conflict and after it
ended the 80 men returned home with an
extra 81st person who was said to be an
italian friend the soldiers made during
the war
hence liechtenstein's army arrived home
stronger than it departed
this was also the last war liechtenstein
participated in as it disbanded its army
in 1868 and announced permanent
neutrality
then on now is this story true well if
you have seen any of my other
well actually videos you should know by
now that oftentimes these things are
based in truth but not
entirely true so let's see where this
one goes wrong
in the latter half of the 19th century
liechtenstein was ruled by johann ii
prince of liechtenstein he was a fairly
liberal ruler for his time
and in 1862 even issued liechtenstein's
first constitution
however also during this time he along
with the entire liechtenstein's upper
class had very close ties to the
austrian empire meaning when the
austro-prussian war started in 1866
the liechtenstein upper class was let's
say
very strongly persuaded to join austria
this didn't sit all too well with the
liechtenstein people who with their new
constitutional government
heavily voiced their concerns like costs
of going to war or the fact that they
didn't want to fight against fellow
germans or simply that no
liechtensteiner really felt like dying
in a war would be a pleasant experience
etc so the prince being pressured by
austria on one side and by his subjects
on the other
had to do some clever political
maneuvering first he assured the
government that he will take on
all the costs of the military campaign
except the mobilization
second he told his subjects that no
liechtensteiner will have to fight
against fellow germans as the
liechtenstein army would be sent against
the italians who were supporting the
prussians in the war
and third the military was technically
under the direct control of the prince
so in the end
under the premise of defending
liechtenstein against the plausible
invading italian army he went around the
liechtenstein's government and sent the
liechtenstein military to guard the
tyron mountain passes with the austrian
tyra
infantry regiments this way
liechtenstein was practically helping
out austria making them happy but at the
same time as stated before the premise
of liechtenstein's military action was
officially defensive meaning they
technically never declared any war
making the liechtensteiners happy at
least
somewhat this combined with the fact
that over the course of the six weeks
from the liechtenstein's army departure
in july to the end of the war in
september the liechtenstein army never
actively fought anyone
means that as you can see on this map
liechtenstein is officially considered
as being neutral during the war
it was never even mentioned in the peace
treaty because despite their support of
austria liechtenstein was never
considered by prussia as being at war
with them
so was the 1866 austro-prussian war the
last war lichtenstein was in
officially no but technically yes i
guess
okay okay but what of the soldiers were
there truly just 80 soldiers that
guarded the tiro pass
well the lichtestein military at the
time had 82 men and 18 in reserve
however according to this one source two
men stayed behind to guard the barracks
and vadut's castle
plus considering that the reserves most
likely wouldn't go to tiro
means that actually just 80 men
participated in the war
so that part is correct lastly did the
liechtenstein soldiers actually come
back with an italian friend
well considering they went to tyrol to
defend against the italians it would be
very unlikely and in fact it didn't
happen
however that's not to say the soldiers
didn't come back with an extra person
they did a lieutenant of the kaiseriager
an austrian terror infantry regiment
accompanied the liechtenstein soldier's
home as a military liaison
which would make sense because as
mentioned before the liechtenstein's
army cooperated with the turo infantry
regiment during the war
whether this austrian lieutenant was
their friend i would like to think so
but he most likely returned back home to
austria after all was said and done
also the state administrator carl house
won hausen and the advisor to the state
and the prince clemens graffon westfalen
met up with the army on the
liechtenstein border and entered
liechtenstein with them
so technically the liechtenstein army
returned with three extra men
however these two were lichtensteiners
or at least people who worked for
liechtenstein just doing their job so i
wouldn't really count it
in the end liechtenstein participated in
the austro-prussian war
kind of it had a military of 80 men kind
of
it returned with an extra friend kind of
and
two years after in 1868 it disbanded its
army and declared permanent neutrality
henceforth
so the austro-prussian war was the last
liechtenstein war
kind of and that is the true story of
what happened with the liechtenstein
military in
1866. i would like to give a shout out
to the liechtenstein state library and
their amazing online archives without it
this video wouldn't be possible they are
such a small country and their online
archives are better than most countries
and if you want to see more history
videos on here subscribe click the bell
icon and stick around for history